The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: This is my
definition, including the method
to paint the car, so
to change its color.
And the question says you create
a car with this line here.
So you're initializing
it with 4 comma 2.
What's a line of code that
changes the color from whatever
it initially is to red?
The first one,
car.paintred, is sort
of attempting to
do the way that we
saw in the right
in the slides where
you calling the class name dot.
But it's missing the self.
So we don't know what
object to call it on.
So that one's out
of the running.
The second one is closer,
but we have red here as
a variable as
opposed to a string.
So that one's not going to work.
The third one looks good.
And the fourth
one is just weird.
I don't think that
one will work.
It's attempting to
put a value for self.
But you've already called mycar
dot instead of the class name
dot.
So here, this isn't
going to work.
So since you already called the
object name dot method name,
you just have to give it the
other parameter that it needs,
which is the color.
I think the majority
have gotten it right.